have we done interviews before together
no but we might not each other well yeah
cuz I feel like I know I've been
watching you for years but I've been
watching you for years my god are you
not okay with watching hey I am just
shook right now so do you have a dog no
I don't deserve you the nice to my dog
I'm in DC he's now nominees yeah and
your dog's name is maverick yes she is
amazing so if someone doesn't if they're
not into dogs how is that a deal breaker
for you that's a good question
kind of yeah that probably means they're
a serial killer just about but don't
trust people who don't like dogs what
good is a dog like er they have to be a
lover can it be a licker what's the
difference I don't know hmm oh yeah it's
very it's white or black I think
mmm is it like is it like I'll take I
want to play but I don't want to pick up
poop that's like like I had a plan with
maverick not sure if I want got those
bags there will be a day yeah no okay
and you guys obviously have great banter
in real life and in the movie and then
for you like seeing use or romantically
like I just think you're funny thank you
so seeing you do anything like romantic
I felt like I wanted to close my eyes
interesting is kind of the first time
I've got a chance to do that outside of
the sitcom world and but I think I was
ready for I was I was excited to do it
and then we by the time we got going and
filming it was very comfortable we we
we've been saying all day that we met a
few hours before our characters met get
out and so then it kind of just develop
organically and now we're doing a sitcom
together really yeah yeah we're we're
romantic on again it's called fan
see ya love I heard about start shooting
next week yeah congratulations and then
I have to ask you of course
Degrassi reunion Drake video Toronto it
was so fun to be home that's I was so
nice to go back to the city and I mean
he's he's turned the city into such a
hot spot for the world really put it on
the map and yeah getting to go back home
on our old stomping grounds and roam the
halls together after so many years was
really special and really cool and did
you get like the call for it was the
text like how did you prepare for it it
was an email yeah it was an email and it
was a no-brainer of course we I think
everybody was stoked to get back
together and see everyone I love how she
was like we were in New York I just
happen to be in New York where she was
in New York yeah we got a chance to hang
out and then the song came on that was
the first time I heard it outside of
after the show but it was crazy is that
the turnaround I mean yeah oh yeah the
email came on a Monday we were shooting
on Friday Saturday Sunday and then it
came out the next Wednesday like the
term they were editing as we were on set
it was amazing and fast I don't know
nobody slept apparently oh my god what
of it the movies so great guys
congratulations thank you alright